más de 72 horas después de los
terremotos en Siria y Turquía muchos
acusan al gobierno Turco de actuar con
lentitud el presidente
erdogan ha visitado varias ciudades para
conocer la situación de primera mano y
realizó promesas de reconstrucción tan
solo tres meses antes de unas elecciones
presidenciales
Nuestro objetivo con el Ministerio del
medio ambiente y urbanismo es
reconstruir la estructura demolida en un
año como edificios de 3 y 4 pisos
en la ciudad de adana una de las más
afectadas en Turquía se instaló el
centro de ayuda más grande en un parque
con 196 tiendas de campaña que acogen a
más de 2.000 personas afectadas por la
catástrofe algunos de los cuerpos no han
logrado ser identificados y reposan en
plazas como estas a la espera de una
despedida digna entre tanto muchos de
los sobrevivientes quedaron sin hogar y
se agrupan en centros de Refugio
buscando calefacción ropa y alimentos
urgentemente las esperanzas de encontrar
sobrevivientes de la catástrofe se
desvanecen y el frío extremo dificulta
las tareas de los rescatistas Mientras
tanto las familias lloran a sus seres
queridos e inician los entierros
colectivos
la gravedad del evento es muy deplo es
como el día del juicio final hay miles
de heridos y muertos estas son tumbas
que se están abriendo recientemente ya
hemos comenzado a enterrar a la gente
aquí créanme no hay familias sin dolor
la mayoría de la gente ni siquiera sabe
qué hacer no sabemos qué sucederá
en Siria finalmente logró pasar el
primer convoy de Naciones Unidas cargado
de ayuda humanitaria el cual no había
podido cruzar la frontera turca debido
al dominio de grupos rebeldes en el
norte del país además muchos de los
edificios que quedaron en pie han sido
evacuados debido a su inminente riesgo
de desplome